hey everyone it's Mike from orphos here
and welcome back to my channel I'm glad
you can join me for today's video I'll
be talking about iceberg orders and
before I jump in you know if you've been
enjoying these videos be sure to
subscribe to the channel click the
notification Bell so you don't miss any
new upload and if you find today's video
helpful be sure to hit the like button
for me and leave a comment sharing your
biggest takeaway you know I do love
hearing your feedback
um actually today's video on icebergs do
come from some of the comments because I
I did get quite a few over the last
couple weeks about uh hey can I do a
video on icebergs you know your support
really does go a long way in helping me
create more awesome content just like
this video so if you're getting value
from my channel and want to see more be
sure to hit that subscribe button and
let's uh grow together right you know I
want to grow this channel out as well as
you know I want you to learn more about
trading specifically with order flow all
right so the topic of icebergs
um you know there's a lot of
conversation in uh trading about iceberg
orders right and what they are so
basically you know an iceberg order is a
large order either a buy or sell that's
intentionally hidden from the market you
know hence the term Iceberg right say
it's in order to sell 300 contracts and
the trader just decides to show 20
contracts at a time the order will
refresh
you know think of it like an iceberg
right only a small uh part of the order
is showing now an iceberg order is
generally going to be a passive order
it's going to be an order that sits on
the bid or sits on the offer now that
doesn't necessarily mean all Iceberg
orders are passive someone can
um you know say the market here is uh
you know 45 21 right there's 105 maybe
they buy 500 at on the offer at 21 show
100 so then it would buy whatever's on
the offer at 21 and it would work a bid
I'm showing just 100 at the time that is
an iceberg that would be an iceberg
order but it it's you know an order
that's lifting the offer right that that
would be an aggressive buy so it could
come in in different forms now
um
originally right with sort of the the
Advent of electronic trading you know
back in the old days in the mid 90s CME
had Globex
um
the cbot had project a I mean initially
it was called Aurora but all intents and
purposes they renamed it to project a
and then nymex comex had what was called
access and the only system at that time
that you were able to hide size was
nymex comex meaning you know the gold
markets copper markets or obviously
crude oil heating oil Etc
um
and you know I have a chart here this is
a footprint chart of crude oil I
actually actually pulled up a
depth map oh sorry a dome rather up
crude just give me a second here
okay and crude is a market you know
we're generally the bid and offer you
got around 20 contracts more or less
sometimes you're going to have a little
bit more sometimes a little bit less but
it's about 20. and I know from
experience in dealing with a lot of crew
Traders
um and trading crew at an Institutional
level at commodity trading firms Etc
that that is a market that generally is
Iceberg regardless anything over you
know 10 or 20 contracts is going to be
Iceberg whether it's Iceberg showing one
contract or showing five contracts or
showing ten contracts
um they're going to Iceberg their orders
that's just sort of in their nature I
think it sort of goes back to the the
older days of when electronic trading
first started in that market that was
just sort of one of the unique features
of it and when you're looking at a
footprint chart okay a footprint chart
is showing you what actually traded in
the market it's not showing you the
depth of the market okay so you don't
know you can't I'll be honest right
you're not going to look at a footprint
chart and say oh this was Iceberg or
this was Iceberg you know this 162 was
iceberg
you don't know that right because you're
just looking at what actually traded the
only way you're going to be able to see
if an order is Iceberg if you're looking
at a dome right the depth of market and
to even a lesser extent if you're
looking at say a heat map and you're
sort of watching what's going on in here
um now if you're looking at you know a
footprint right if I'm looking here
again
right now this Market is trading what is
it trading 19 19 and a quarter I see the
bids and offers being traded I'm not
looking at how the depth is changing I'd
have to be watching a dome so people
honestly
take it
as a grain of salt in the sense that
most Iceberg orders over a certain size
are going to be hidden okay for example
okay so you see crude right
21 by 2 but the size in here you know
it's about you know 35 63 72 20 you know
even on the bid 55 52 17 18 18. if I
look on the crew chart you know I'm
seeing obviously more size than that
going through Arc 65 89 72 113 55. so
generally speaking
there's icebergs in here right and I I
understand that more size is going to
come in
um you know when you start getting a
little bit closer I mean that's how
Traders work you know
um Algos are taught that you know
especially a lot of these high frequency
trading you know they're going to work a
bit as soon as that could filled they're
going to work an offer
um all day long that's what a lot of
hfts hfts do but as a market going up
and and this is something that
retail Traders don't understand okay
what they do is they see a market going
up because I've seen people explain
icebergs like this ah this sub 172 is
Iceberg this 162 is Iceberg
um you know the 160 the 109 it's Iceberg
yeah it probably is but that's just sort
of a side effect of of a large order
right large orders people want to hide
the size does it have special meaning
some icebergs do but I'll get to that in
a moment but if a market is going up and
it's making new highs
and you're a big Trader you have Supply
to sell
where do you want to sell on a market
that's rallying or a market that's
selling off
well it's going to be easier to sell the
liquidity is going to be there that buy
side liquidity that aggressive buying is
going to be there
on the way up
so if if you're an Institutional Trader
if you're a big Trader and you got a lot
of size to sell a lot of contracts to to
move the easiest place for you to get
rid of them is on a rising market so I'm
not surprised to see big volumes coming
up here on the offer side as the
Market's going up now it was 172 showing
probably not 162 showing probably not
you know
it was probably showing you know if the
order was for 50 maybe it's showing 10
contracts now does that make this
Iceberg order something special no it's
just a large order the trader doesn't
want to reveal what he's doing but if a
market is going up I'm expecting
there to be Supply on the way up because
I know as as again I've been an
Institutional Trader I know that the
easiest place to sell is in a rising
market am I going to sell exactly at the
top no I don't need to right because if
I've already identified that hey you
know what 8900 is a good price to be
selling at I'll be dropping my offer in
I'll be dropping it at 95 right you can
see here another five cents higher and
another five cents higher and I'm just
averaging my price that's what
institutional Traders do they average
price they don't pick a certain level
and try to you know be that specific
they're going to average in and out of
their trades now
if the market starts falling and you're
an Institutional Trader all you're doing
is you're making the situation worse
because now you've got Supply to sell
but the Market's already falling
you know if you're sitting here oh you
know I got to sell you know it's trading
89 bucks and then gets all the way up to
89.21
and then you're thinking oh you know
then you start seeing a drop you know
maybe you're thinking oh I'm gonna be
smart you know institutional Traders got
a lot on their plate right they're not
trying to micromanage every single tick
that goes through they're not going to
sit here you know they have their levels
89 bucks 89.50 90 bucks then if the
market starts drip going lower next
thing you know oh I missed my 89s
because I'm I got greedy up here at 89
then they start coming in with Supply
coming in at 90 you know at 75. they're
just pushing the market against
themselves okay that's not how
institutional Traders think when a
rising market and they got something
they already think it's in the money
it's a good place to sell that's where
they're going to get out okay now I see
some
gurus online I I don't like to call
myself a guru you know I just speak for
my own experience but they'll say oh you
got big size up here um it must have
been an iceberg order
okay so what really where you're going
to want to see an iceberg order come in
and honestly the only way you're going
to see it is if you're watching what's
trading on a dome or you're watching the
depth of the market and you're watching
it refresh right because you don't know
if you're looking at a footprint it's
static
okay they're gonna say well you know if
Market is going up and then it just
starts going sideways and you're
starting to seeing size come in then
um you know that's a sign of an iceberg
because the market is struggling to go
up but really what an iceberg is it's
going to be that constant refreshing of
the offer if they're you know
at a high price but you know that what
some people say is though you got
icebergs coming in here so it's going to
be bearish but really all you're seeing
is Supply coming into the market okay
now getting back to which icebergs
matter
in a rising market an iceberg on the
offer it doesn't matter
a little bit but really what you want to
see and again it's hard you'd be
guessing looking after the fact at a
footprint chart that there's an iceberg
order here but probably there was
honestly but you honestly you'd have to
be looking at a depth of market right to
see people selling into the bid and that
bid refreshing you know 17 Lots trade at
uh 22. that next thing you know there's
25 again there that 25 trades next thing
you know there's 25 again there okay
you'd have to be watching that that's
one of the benefits of of using a dome
but honestly you know if you're doing
crude oil it's pretty calm right now but
if you're you know say you're say you're
looking at uh you know NQ
all right we're just jumping around it's
going to be difficult for you to to
accurately say yeah there was an iceberg
order now there are tools out there like
bookmap has one and Iceberg uh tool I I
don't use a book map so I'm not going to
say whether it's good or not you know
they they have great tools so I'm
assuming it's it's a legitimate tool
there's some thoughts that go into it
and
you know what is interesting you know I
don't know if they're doing it but if
they are then those their programmers
are smart the guy the team behind there
I know for a fact that at CME unless
it's changed since I I left that
industry you know in that sense of
working at the bank I know that there's
what an order generates right when you
click in order to go in what is
generated from The Exchange is a ton
number ticket order number t-o-n refer
to ton if you got to call the exchange
if there's a problem with the order
so if you're going to buy
500 emini s PS and show 25 that order
for 500 would have a unique ton number
right a t-o-n number
and that's how you would identify the
actual order but if that was an iceberg
order it would know based off that ton
number
that the order is being refreshed but
that's that's a little bit deeper I
don't know if the exchange
puts that information out to sort of to
the public or you know
that can be used to
you know program something around but
that is you know ways that the exchange
can is able to identify it I don't know
if that information is publicly
available
but anyway
if the market is going up right this
142. so if I see 88.83 and I see 20 Lots
on the bid and then it trades out then
another 20 Lots come in it gets
refreshed
that's where I'm going to be interested
in an iceberg I'm not going to be
interested in a rising market with an
iceberg
because that's where I'm expecting you
know Supply to be coming in but if I'm
making new highs
and I see big bids coming in like here
right the 142. now again I don't know if
it's honestly if I'm looking at
footprint I don't care if it's an
iceberg or not at this point I I know I
have demand coming in I know I have a
big supportive bid coming in right here
at 88.83 right 142 contracts traded to
me that is important to know
it most likely it's going to be an
iceberg again anything in crude oil
you know above a certain size
above 20 contracts is going to be
Iceberg anyway
okay so you know sometimes you know
people they like to associate volume
like increases in volume and
um
you know and the price not moving
as an iceberg when really what that is
is it's absorption taking place or
distribution right if the market was
going down and you see strong selling
going in there it's being absorbed yeah
it's probably being absorbed by an
iceberg order because again pretty much
anything over a certain size is going to
be Iceberg you know the average trade on
the CME
is like especially like in the
e-minis is like a 1.4 contracts
okay if you don't believe me I mean
let's take a look here okay we'll go on
on a footprint if I were to
let's see here okay well just keep it
simple right a tick chart
right tick chart is per trade right
and you're seeing in here right each bar
1588 contracts one thousand six hundred
one thousand five hundred one thousand
four hundred one thousand seven hundred
one thousand eight hundred one thousand
five one thousand five one thousand four
one thousand four so you know it is
about one and a half contracts I mean
some bars you're gonna be bigger here's
two and a half thousand
um over here is thirteen hundred okay so
you know that's what execute the you
know the rise of the Algos are doing now
they're breaking down big orders into
small size whether it's trading on the
bid or whether it's trading on the offer
okay because you know any sort of thing
that's going to show up here on the dome
right people don't you know just go back
here right to the e-minis you can see
the app the contracts one contract
traded okay
that's what that one is there how many
contracts traded I mean there's going to
be times you're gonna see a hundred
flash through now again you know
something you know here I it jumped up
um you know some of the domes out there
this is just the basic Dome from Ninja
Trader okay jigsaw has a great Dome
um you know where it will track the
volume they're traded at each price or
the inside bit and offer
um what what traded through at you know
at different prices which you know is
probably can be important to use if you
want to use it in your volume but you
know to sit here and say oh look at this
the market came down here and I'm seeing
some size go through that there's got to
be an iceberg really what you're looking
at is absorption
um people are sort of
distorting the whole concept of icebergs
and to be honest most orders are Iceberg
if you go to talk to you know an
Institutional trading desk you know the
the order executioner that guy he's
going to tell you he's iceberg in the
orders right because last thing that
they want to do right you want one if it
trades you want to participate but two
last thing you want to do is Telegraph
to the whole world what you're trying to
do
so again you know it let's just go
really quick to a
well we'll go to
um you know a contract that trades a lot
of volume 10 years I'm not going to use
a thousand tick I'll use a four range
chart
all right because 10 years
these two ten years you know several
thousand at each level okay it's a very
deep and liquid Market you can see over
here traded
um 12 600.
right when it was offered at the 109 23
and a half
you see any really big size in here I
mean up here at 29 and a half up here
just right above the high of the day
you know there's 27 000 that's pretty
big right okay but I think as if we get
up there it'll probably dissipate a bit
okay
um but you see here what's trading 17
contracts last trade went through
so even though there's a lot of size
doesn't necessarily mean there's a lot
of size going through
now on a deeper contract like like
treasuries yeah if someone's got ten
thousand to sell maybe they're showing
two thousand
maybe there's you know I very rarely
you're going to see a size like 27 000
but I mean you can we're sort of showing
all so again you know the whole point of
showing 27 000
up here above the high of the day I know
people can get excited get a hard on
because oh there's 27 000 you know we
can't possibly trade up well we we can
right and you got to watch right if it's
going to stay or not it could thin out
right if we start getting up to 28 28
and a half I think this 27 000 is going
to go down to
five thousand I mean that that's just my
own
um based on my own experience right
cancel if close that was always the joke
right people would see size in the
market and cancel if close all right so
that's sort of my uh video on the
subject of icebergs
um are icebergs important yes and no I
think it's more important on where they
come in but again really to identify an
iceberg you'll truly identify an iceberg
as a Trader you know you're going to be
want to focusing on the Dome because
looking at a footprint and trying to
ascertain there was an iceberg here you
can't you're just you're just guessing
okay because one is you're just looking
at the volume after the fact and you
know I don't wanna
mislead people and thinking that yeah I
can see it hey you know what there was
an iceberg here when one I wasn't
watching it and I can't say for
certainty that there was but
you know maybe there's an iceberg
honestly most orders over a certain size
are Iceberg anyway but
um if you're watching a dome
you can see where the icebergs are
coming in and when they're trading all
right guys so uh if you've enjoyed this
video be sure to hit that like button
And subscribe to the channel if you
haven't already so you don't miss any
more of my new videos so thanks for
watching being a part of my order flow
community
all right everyone take care
yeah